and that white ball of light began to
slowly move to the very center of the
room and as it did it got larger and
larger and larger and then it stopped
and then the silver light began to
shimmer up and down like strands of
silver light in the middle of that ball
and then began to take form
and suddenly
there was my little cheerleader
so what would you do if your deceased
loved one showed up and started having
conversations with you find out on this
episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
hey everybody welcome back to led live
today you are going to be glad that you
showed up for this show because it is a
crazy story you know what happens
when you die i think is a big question
that a lot of people have in our world
and
it's not every day that you meet
somebody that had communications with
somebody who had died in their life and
so
today we have paul volk with us and he
has a awesome ministry you travel around
and speak in schools and churches and
you travel around the world right about
45 countries now that's pretty amazing
and so
i'm excited to jump into this and hear
your testimony because this is something
that personally happened to you
and
we want to know
why or how did this all begin
yes well it was
my senior year of high school and i went
to a school of about 900 students
beginning of every school year all of us
guys were walking around on our tiptoes
looking over the new crop of girls that
showed up over the summer
and i was heading up the north hallway
and a young lady with long brown hair
bright blue eyes a spring in her step
and a sparkle on her face and as soon as
she passed i followed
and so i knew she was a new girl i
didn't know where she was from but i
started asking her but you got her in a
class you know her name we know who she
is finally a friend introduced us and i
was so happy chris mcdaniel now i know
her name
so we got introduced and i would run
around the hallway to make sure i was
heading in the opposite direction that i
knew she had to go to for her next class
and i'd be walking down real cool
she'd be coming the other way i'd say hi
chris she'd say hi paul
well after a couple of weeks
because i'm very shy by nature i mean
god has given me holy boldness but i'm
very shy
and so i built up my courage and i asked
her out for a date and she said no i
said that's okay she's so beautiful
and uh so a couple more weeks i couldn't
help myself i asked for a second time
she said no again
a few more weeks i couldn't help myself
i asked her out a third time and she
said no i said okay strike three you're
out
you know squeaky wheel gets the grease
right yeah but a couple of days later
the girl who introduced us said hey i
hear you've been asking that chris
mcdonald girl out and i says oh man
don't tell anybody i'm so embarrassed
you know i got the picture she says you
know what you're doing wrong what do you
mean you keep asking her for that coming
weekend every guy on campus is asking
her out she's booked you need to ask her
farther ahead so i ran home i opened up
my calendar and i picked something one
month away
november 11.
next day i went to school i said chris
is this big event going on at west high
school and i thought if you weren't busy
on november 11th we could go
and she said
yes i was so excited i jumped up and
down i got all mick and sheila and i
said you got to double with this because
i don't know what's in on how to talk i
don't know what to do all the talking if
you're there there's four before it's
gonna talk and i don't know the talking
and they said calm down paul calm down
you know we'll double date with you so i
had one month to iron my socks to grow
my pimples together
and the day arrived so so excited and uh
it was an all-day event so halfway
through we went to a restaurant to go
get something to eat and as soon as i
pulled into the parking lot mickey and
sheila jump out of the car and they
began to race to see who could get to
the front door first well i saw what
they were doing i said hey hey so i
jumped out and i started running trying
to catch up to them and i realized chris
was still back at the car
and so i said come on chris hurry up and
she started running and i held out my
hand and she slipped her little hand
into mine and my feet didn't touch the
ground the rest of the day
so this was my senior year
and she was a sophomore
and
so
we
we went to the prom together
and
there we are at the prom
after graduation
we decided we were going to keep a
long-distance relationship i was going
outside to college in alaska that's what
we call the lower 48 outside
and
so we kept a long-distance relationship
she said you know next year
i'm a junior i'm eligible to try out for
cheerleading do you mind if i try out to
cheer and i said why not well some guys
are possessive and insecure and jealous
and they don't want their girlfriends
being cheerleaders i said no go ahead i
mean over 900 students only six
cheerleaders right she tried out and she
actually made the squad
nice i was so happy for her and uh so i
went away to college i come back
christmas time we spend the holidays
together then i back off to college
again now is her senior year she said
can i try out again i said sure go ahead
well this time she not only made the
squad she became the captain our head
varsity cheerleader and we always send
our cheerleader to a camp in california
where thousands of cheerleaders from all
over the nations
come to order their new uniforms learn
their new flips their yells their jumps
and so on so she was sent down there
so
i came back home she was on full
scholarship now at a private university
when she graduated she was very
intelligent
and
anyway
we decided
um
things were getting more serious and we
wanted to see how we're gonna do the
future and so i had two more years to
finish college and i said well why don't
we finish i finish college and then you
do your last two years
and uh then we'll get married
and i had the names of our first two
kids already picked out
if it was christopher michael it was
going to be a boy christine michelle if
it was a girl
robert james was the next boy and then
she could name all the rest
well anyway i was home at christmas time
and we were walking down the hallway we
passed by the trophy case where all the
banners and the awards are and i saw
this gold baton laying on the in the
case and her name was engraved on it
and i said chris what what is this about
she goes oh
that's nothing from the scope
and i said no what your name is on this
why is that on there she goes really
it's not anything
so i grabbed one of the other students
and i said how come chris's name was on
this baton and he said well didn't you
know she went to cheerleading camp she
was our head cheerleader i said yeah i
knew that while it was at the camp she
was voted the most outstanding
cheerleader in the united states oh wow
she never told me that because she's a
very humble girl she says you know we
all had fun at the camp
they were just really nice to me
come on let's go
so i said yep this is the one
so i was back at college first week in
march i get a phone call up from alaska
and uh
she talked for a few minutes and she
goes has anybody from up here called you
in the last 24 hours and i said well no
i was just home for christmas and she
said then you didn't hear about the
accident
i said was anybody hurt
and she began to cry
and i said chris is all right isn't she
and she said there was a wrestling
tournament last night three of our
cheerleaders rode home with one of the
wrestlers and i said is she in the
hospital is she in the hospital
and she said ah that was a drunk driver
and a head on collision
gloria cheryl died last night
and i'm sorry to tell you
chris is dead and i said no
you got to get her to the hospital those
doctors can do something they can't let
her go you don't do it please just just
get her to the hospital i'll be right up
she said i'm sorry paul all three
cheerleaders died instantly in the
head-on collision so i'll never get to
hold christine michelle in my arms i'll
never get to see my robbie boy grow up
because some person decided they would
drink and drive and now you know one of
the reasons i go into the high schools
because if i can help somebody else not
go what i went through these girls would
not have died in vain
so
they had the funeral for i dropped out
of college i flew home went to the
funeral of all three girls at the end of
the funerals my parents asked me what i
wanted to do and i said nothing i have
no tomorrow all right my future is all
gone i don't want to do anything
and they said well just take the credit
cards and go do what you need to do
so i flew down to um
after the funerals were over and went to
the funeral of all the three girls
and i flew down to arizona to stay with
some friends
and i was there for about two weeks
and suddenly i was awakened in the
middle of the night
but you said nobody knew you were going
except your mom that's right when my
parents asked me when to go and i said
mom i don't want any phone calls i don't
want to talk to anybody
i'm going to tell you where i'm at
don't even tell my brother i don't want
anyone to know
and she said you got it she says where
you going i'm going to stay with barb
and russell marie in tucson she goes
okay i know where you're at
so anyway i got down there and after
about two weeks i was awakened in the
middle of the night and there was this
pink swirling light that filled my room
now chris's casket was a pink crushed
velvet casket the same pink color was
swirling around my room so i thought
well maybe there's a car backing up
outside
there was nothing out there this light
was in my room i wasn't coming in my
room
so i sat there for a few moments and
then suddenly in the far corner of the
room a white ball of light appeared well
now it got my attention i rubbed my eyes
and i looked again and that white ball
of light began to slowly move to the
very center of the room and as it did it
got larger and larger and larger and
then it stopped
and then the silver light began to
shimmer up and down like strands of
silver light in the middle of that ball
and then began to take form
and suddenly
there was my little cheerleader
wow i was so happy
i remember walking across the cold floor
in my bare feet i put my arms around her
waist she put her arms around my neck
she kissed me here and she said please
don't cry anymore
i'm all right
now you're not doing drugs right no
that's clean
yeah i was only 20 years old
man and so um
when i had that experience um
i sat down and i wrote a four-page
letter about my feelings and my future
and i mailed it back to a friend back in
alaska she was so touched by this letter
that she took it to school and she
started sharing with everybody and
everybody was crying you know reading
the letter
one of the cheerleaders
saw the letter and she started screaming
hysterically running up and down the
hallways and everybody said billy what's
the matter what's the matter and she
said it's true it's true i was afraid to
tell anybody because you thought i was
crazy but now i know it's true and they
said what what is it
and she said look you guys
i came home one night and gloria one of
the other cheerleaders was sitting on my
dresser and when i stepped inside my
bedroom i she said what are you doing
here you girls are dead and she goes i
know but we died so suddenly in the car
accident
god gave us all permission to come back
to the earth to say goodbye to our loved
ones wow and she goes okay where's
gloria she's with her fiance and what
about chris where's she at
she says well you know i don't know when
we were coming back to earth chris said
she had to stop off in arizona and she
would catch up with the rest of us later
so she was asking everybody who's in
arizona who's in arizona nobody's in
arizona who's in arizona why would
anybody be in arizona
nobody knew but when she saw my letter
and she turned it over and she saw the
postmark tucson arizona oh wow that's
when she flipped out because she says
now i know why she told me chris was in
arizona paul's there and nobody knew i
was there except my mother and satan wow
so he tried to arrange all that so a lot
of supernatural things happened
after the girls died and everybody was
just a little buzz everybody was sharing
with everybody you know satan realized
he had a gold mine here
and to to try to confuse people about
what scripture has to say
so so before you before you move on to
that are you are you saying like you're
in a public school setting
so are any of these kids like coming
from really religious homes or
like what was the what was the their
friends and colleagues and was everybody
now starting to talk about god and
actually some of them their their
fathers were preachers
in in town the uh jamie cron her dad uh
was the big baptist church downtown that
was her dad and uh sandy's father was
the preacher at a methodist church
and uh
they uh
yeah
so uh
anyway
billy uh
realized that
what was going on and she told everybody
and everybody just went into you know
ecstaticness because they said wow they
made it the girls made it they're all in
heaven
and uh
so then um
oh when i came back home i had her
senior port was above my bed on the wall
and it had been there for a couple years
when i came home i opened up my bedroom
door that portrait had fallen off the
bed fallen off the wall bounced on the
bed landed on the floor and she was
facing me
as i opened the door and when i opened
the door i looked right at her i didn't
look at the doors the windows nothing as
soon as i opened the door my eyes were
right on her and it was like she was
saying i'm here wow i'm here
so so are you saying that how long had
she how long had it been from her
passing to when you saw the visitation
uh weeks weeks yeah and when you saw
that it was physical it wasn't just like
this
hologram type thing like you embraced
her no i picked the picture up oh we're
not yeah in person oh yeah she was warm
and you know the thing about was she was
so beautiful i was afraid to touch her
because i didn't know if i was going to
get shocked or something so when you
hugged her you physically felt something
oh yeah yeah and did you talk uh no i
didn't i was too
overwhelmed i mean it was like a light
bulb was on inside of her she just
radiated she just glowed she was so
beautiful i just i could hardly breathe
looking at her i just was going
mom yeah and then there was no fear or
anything no it's not afraid there was
just bedazzling well i didn't know
anything about the bible so i would
naturally assume what i was experiencing
was supposed to happen yeah so tell us a
little bit about where you were in your
understanding of god or anything at this
point well i had a quite quite a
potpourri my father was a roman catholic
my mother a methodist sunday school
teacher my brother and elder in the
mormon church and i went to baptist
bible school so you were a mutt yes i
had a lot of christianity you know but
if you ask any of them to find the book
of luke they probably couldn't do it
and it's very common for mormons to have
visitations from dead loved ones i hear
that's like the best testimony is when
is it a dead loved one tells you you're
in the right church so it's kind of
common actually
well if that was a visitation they
probably were in the right
but anyway
joke there yeah
so
i i
told my friends
i said now listen um
if anything happens to me and i die
before jesus comes
this is where she's buried and i said i
want to be cremated and then i want my
ashes put right where she is
because on that resurrection morning
i don't i want her to be the first one
that i see
and so they said we promise paul we'll
make sure that happens
so
uh on that resurrection morning i'm
going to hold out my hand like that
first date and she'll slip her hand into
mind and our feet really won't touch the
ground this is her senior portrait
and this other one was the small picture
was the one i took of her for her first
birthday that we had together
and uh
yeah it was just she was just the most
amazing person i'd ever met and we had
an amazing three years together uh that
we had i never heard her complain i
never heard her make bad jokes about
anybody every time she would hear us
talking bad about somebody she knew
something good about them you know
they're an a student in math class they
helped us put up the posters for the pep
rally you know she knew something good
about everybody and so you couldn't talk
too much bad about anybody because she
would say well wait a minute there did
you know her you know
it was amazing
so one of the things that really blessed
me was i always went to high school
reunions because obviously she was two
years behind me so i knew a lot of her
classmates and of course they knew who i
was
and i went to her tenure her 20 year and
her 30 year and we got up to her 30-year
reunion
gwen who was organizing the reunion she
said paul we're going to do something
special this year additionally we've
never done at any reunion what are you
going to do
we're going to go visit the gravesites
of all three girls
i'm like oh that could be a little tough
and she said i know i know but we've all
decided on the committee that it's time
that we go visit
i said sure and she said i need you to
do a special favor for me and i said
what do you want me to do she says i
want you
to give an altar call to her classmates
wow i said what and she said paul some
of our classmates are not saved
and she said you know chris was supposed
to have gotten baptized the end of march
and i said yeah i know and that was
another little sideline story in january
of that year she told her dad for her
new year's resolution she says i i want
to get baptized
and he said well just pick a church you
know and the church that she picked was
anchor park methodist my parents were
married there my cousin was married
there
my grandfather built the church the
cross that was in that church it was our
family church that's why i went to
sunday school and of all the churches
she could have picked she picked our
family church so i thought that was kind
of interesting was she did she know that
or just coincidence yeah she didn't know
actually one of her classmates her dad
was that happened to be the pastor there
at the time and so she said hey sandy i
want to get baptized she says yeah we'll
just talk to my dad and we'll get
baptized so they've gone through some
studies
for january and february and they said
you're we're ready to baptize you the
end of march but on march 6th
she took her arrest and you could
already see the christ-like spirit she
had you know yes even before her baptism
yeah her baptism was just a a
demonstration of her commitment
so anyway i told gwen i said gwen you
know i really don't know if i can do
this it's very emotional
as you can tell
so i said i prayed about it and she said
paul this will be the last appeal chris
can make to her classmates
and you're her voice you have to be her
voice and i said you know you're right
you're right i'll do it
and so i bought a case of steps to
christ
all the guys brought their guitars and
we were singing bridge over troubled
water and all these songs from the 60s
and this is the the grave site
where she was
and uh our school colors were red and
blue so we had everything there and
then gwen nodded her head to me and so i
got up
and i said you know the 10-year reunion
was fun we had lots of good times 20 was
great here we are at the 30.
but there is a reunion coming
that is more outstanding than all the
reunions we've ever been to
and there's a little girl down here
waiting for you guys on that
resurrection morning and she wants to
see every one of you ready for that
resurrection morning and none of us
missing from the class of 1970
and so i said i want you to make that
same commitment that jesus that chris
did for jesus in preparing for baptism
and i have a book here steps to christ
that will help you take your steps to
christ and be there for that reunion
okay now i have a question
so
if you really believed that that was her
that showed up and talked with you
at this point
where are you spiritually like are you
are you thinking she's dead because you
mentioned she's in the ground but yet
you mentioned earlier that she showed up
so at what point did you realize she's
either dead or she really was walking
around well
she died in 1970
1973 is what i found out what the bible
says about it so three years later so
three years later is when i knew and
actually i was going to reject that
teaching saying you guys have
misunderstood it because i have proof
and so to a lot of other people that the
dead are alive and visiting
and so i had to struggle and make a
decision between the bible and my
experience now the devil knew if i chose
my experience he had me because i had no
book to get me through
but i decided to choose the bible and
came to the conclusion that that was a
demon who actually came to visit me
so what verse was it that just
spoke to you ecclesiastes
i remember this evangelist holding up
that bible and he said the dead no not
anything and i said preacher you know
not
anything
so he just kept flying through the bible
you know uh all the time when these
kings died it says and they slept with
their fathers and they slept with their
fathers about 30 40 times it says that
slept with their fathers and if you get
a concordance out and you look up the
word sleep you'll be amazed it doesn't
mean snoring yeah that means
they're waiting for the resurrection
morning and what clicked in my brain was
they kept every and everybody knows this
there's going to be a judgment day
coming everybody will say is there a
judgment yeah there's a judgment day
coming i said then how did they get into
heaven if the judgment's still coming
wow oh that's an interesting thing they
haven't been judged so how can they get
there and they go but
i don't know and i said well maybe
because
they're not there yet because nobody's
there because well except enoch and
elijah and those who rose with jesus on
the resurrection
but uh also jesus when he ascended he
said i'm going to prepare a place for
you and when i come back i'll take you
to that place right so why would they
party there before he's come back
yeah and jesus also making the statement
to the thief on the cross saying that
today you will be with me in paradise
but he didn't go to paradise
that day he was in the grave for at
least three days so that statement
wouldn't make sense in the in the term
of when you die all of a sudden you're
both up in heaven exactly but but his
next thought
dying like asleep you wake up in the
morning it's like all of a sudden he's
like yeah to him it pers he perceived
that he was in heaven that next day but
literally it's the argument thousands of
years that had gone by where was jesus
while he was in the tomb was he really
with his father but
when mary came to the tomb and it was
empty he came up behind her and she
thought he was the gardener and he said
don't touch me because i have not yet
ascended to the father this was three
days after his death he's saying i have
not ascended to the father yet people
will look at that scripture where he
says today you'll be with me in paradise
how could that thief be with jesus in
paradise if three days later he says i
haven't even sent it to the father yet
yeah it's a matter of punctuation yeah
the way he said it was
i'm telling you today comma this day
while it looks like it's no good yeah
i'm telling you today you will that's
future tense you will be with me in
paradise yeah man that's awesome
it's great i'm telling you today next
week we're going to be hanging out you
know yeah that's right yeah we're going
to the beach yeah yeah i'm heading to
florida in january so so what was that
like when all of a sudden you're hearing
these words from the bible and you're
just like okay
who was that that showed up then and i'm
i'm embracing this feeling this love i
mean did all of a sudden the hair go up
on the back your neck and you just
realize like oh wow i was just
confronted with a demon
well and it was painful too because i
had to put away
the last
experience we had together that i
thought was our last experience together
and so i had to
i had to deny that and that was very
hard because when you're emotionally
attached to something it's hard to
detach from it
and so
yeah i came to the conclusion
quite clearly i was day and night just
studying this out looking everywhere
for the loophole you know
and then i had non uh biblical friends
who claimed to be christians and they
were trying to explain it to me and i'm
gonna that doesn't feel that doesn't
work what about this what about this and
they just were they were just
tying a
noose around their neck
who was that in the past that
you know had uh some sort of seance and
then their loved one was showing up it
was like one of the inventors it's
actually a lot of them and and they
actually knew that that person was dead
but it was the emotional
rollercoaster of of interacting and he
was fearful to tell his wife who was
that i don't remember which one um i
don't i don't remember any of them the
the to fear is
feared telling his wife but there there
was
sir william crooks the guy that invented
the radiometer and founded the element
valium he started going to seances
after his brother died a friend is the
guy that's been invented the cathode ray
tube
uh so helped envelop and then television
and so he he started going
um the same kind of situation
or
maybe not exactly thomas watson who
helped bell develop the telephone he
went to seances every night
john logie baird who also helped develop
television
marconi who is no won a nobel peace
prize for developing radio
he was regularly going to seances
um let's see
alexander graham bell
dabbled with it
but
he was never really convinced like you
can go to library congress and leave
read letters from him to his aunt mabel
and he's like you know i
you know i had these little seances all
by myself but in my room with the half
hope have fear of receiving some
communication he didn't really buy into
it though um
uh marie curie her husband he was really
into it but after he died she
didn't really
get into that
hardly at all maybe once she went after
that
uh let's see yeah there's just a lot of
inventors a lot of scientists in
victorian
times that
really delved
heavily into spiritualism yeah so what
what is the danger of of believing
that these beings are real what what
could be a potential danger of that
well i think clearly that they will give
you a message
that's not biblical
and they'll say you know i was with god
he wanted to make sure to straighten
this out for you and that this is what
is actually god meant
and so they can send us false messages
and then we end up believing a lie
i've heard near-death experiences where
people are going to the light and stuff
and they're like
i asked the light does everybody
experience this and the light said yeah
and she goes even hitler and the light
said yeah and so when she came back or
whatever she said i'm no longer afraid
of death we're all going to get to
experience this god accepts everyone and
it's love and that's all i felt
and so yeah it'd be very easy for
someone to come back your dead loved one
and say god loves everyone everyone's
going to make it here
and
you also have to believe what the bible
says that you know the wages of sin is
death
that doesn't mean that you're alive even
if you're being tortured forever
you have to to believe the bible says
when you die you die
because then obviously it wouldn't be
that it would be you know like forever
and ever like there's the immortal soul
i think that the huge key in all of this
is ecclesiastes 9 5. if you really take
that scripture and slow down it says for
the living know that they will die
but the dead know not anything why would
the bible say
that dead don't know anything why even
mention that
what's the point i shared romans 6 with
a
assembly of god pastor and uh i said you
know romans 6
the free gift to god has eternal life
through jesus christ but the wages of
sin like you said brother is death
and i said eternal life is a gift that
god only gives to the righteous
eternal life doesn't go to the wicked
it's a gift
and boy did a light go on in his head
and he goes i've known that text all my
life this is the first time i understood
it
and it just doesn't make sense to me um
if you think like okay you die and all
of a sudden your soul goes to heaven
when god comes on judgment day
and is is you know resurrecting people
either his first his second coming right
he's resurrecting people to go up into
heaven with him well what about all
those dead people that are supposedly
going to get raised from the from the
dead if they're in heaven is it like
okay everybody's got to go back down to
earth and and watch jesus come and be
excited about it you've already been up
there with him you know that doesn't
make any logical sense yeah i was raised
in churches that believe that they will
say when you die your spirit
comes out of your body goes to heaven
but it's not really that fun because you
don't have a body you don't have eyes or
a tongue or anything so
when he comes back then you get to go
back to your body now you get to enjoy
heaven and your physical body which is
far better there's like these verses
that they even use where it says
it's far body far better to have your
body but
when you look at
what happens when christ comes back
when adam and eve sinned
they were separated from the tree of
life that tree of life enabled them to
be immortal so when they got separated
now death is inevitable
and the bible says that
those who keep the commandments of god
will have right to the tree of life yeah
so when he comes back we're gonna the
righteous are going to put on
immortality we're gonna get the gift of
god which is everlasting life and have
right to the tree of life if you don't
have
the gift of god
which is everlasting life and you're not
going to get to put on immortality and
you're not one of those who have right
to the tree of life
which our bible specifically says that
they had god removed the tree of life
lest he live forever yeah be an immortal
sin or whatever right and it says only
god has immortality yeah so he's the
only one who can give it because he's
the only one who has it
so we know that that satan has long been
preparing his final you know his final
thing that he's going to try to do we
know that he's going to blend
um spiritualism and and you know people
who are who are putting their trust in
their eyes instead of their trust in
thus saith the word of god that's why
it's so much more important to to say i
don't care what what what is shown to me
i don't care what if i feel like this is
the right thing you got to go back to
the bible and you got to say but it says
that the dead know not anything i know
who you are and i'm not going to listen
to you so i've heard
similar type stories um to this before
but a lot of times in those stories once
people learn what the bible says
that
being
comes back
and they're not so nice anymore
did you experience that did you ever get
visited by chris again and how did that
go
not by chris but
after my baptism
i was a life insurance agent at the time
and i had
way too much money for somebody my age
and
so
after i got baptized i found out that
the adventists had bible colleges and i
said great i got to find out what a
shadrack is because i didn't know
anything so i went to puc
and i wanted to live in the village so
there was a an elderly who rented out
rooms so
she just had one room there and she
rented it out to me
and
was on the side of the house and every
night i would open the window while i
slept because it was still warm enough
out so i left the window wide open while
i was sleeping
one night i was sound to sleep now
back up a little bit i think the reason
that satan has certain privileges with
me is because i used to own three ouija
boards
and so that gave him permission when you
own things you got tarot cards in your
house and demonic posters and pentagrams
you better get them out because you give
them permission i mean it's it's even
goes one step further i mean you listen
to what john todd said from the 70s
where he worked for the music industry
specifically capitol records and stuff
and he went you want to know how many
demons you have in your house go count
your records
and so you know it's not just those kind
of devices it's the movies it's the
music it's the you know you got some
pretty evil things in your house that's
right like you said it gives the devil
license to be there that's right and he
did and uh boy after i got baptized i i
came home i put those ouija boards in
the backyard i lit a match and i ran and
then they didn't burn
they burned
i started singing
trying to burn them and they don't burn
yeah yeah i've heard they go around
spinning in the air and that's why i ran
yeah i literally so when you did you
play with them as oh yeah ever yes yes
well you had a recent three of them i
mean one is not enough
yeah they were all christmas presents oh
which is crazy yeah i know
so you didn't even you didn't finish
going into your windows open you're
going to sleep hey the window's open i'm
sound asleep
and then all of a sudden i feel this
really cold air
it was so cold it woke me up
and i thought
man what's that
and then i realized this was an old
house so they had big eight ten foot
ceilings in this house
you know and i and i looked at the end
of my bed and i realized there was
something darker
at the end of my bed who went clear to
the ceiling
and i thought
somebody's in here
you know
and i was scared to make a sound and so
i waited for a few moments and all of a
sudden these giant hands like this wide
grabbed my ankles
and my heart went into my throat all
right you know and i just went oh he's
gonna tick me like a ragdoll and slam me
against the wall
and so i waited for a few minutes i was
so scared i couldn't even yell out for
my landlady to hear me no
and then the hands moved
up to my calves i mean
big hands like this right around my
calves
and i said this is it man here comes the
slam you know and then a second later he
moved up to right below my kneecaps and
i said all right here we go
and finally i didn't know what to do and
i said
in the name of the lord jesus christ i
rebuke you
and he let go wow
and nothing was in the room
man my heart was just pounding of course
i didn't get to sleep for hours
so about a week later
same thing a cold air comes into my
bedroom now
i'm there studying about god and trying
to learn the bible and satan is trying
to scare me
i see what this is all the scenario
so then the cold air comes in
i sat up and i went oh no but i couldn't
see this
black
giant figure at the end of my bed
so i had a headlight on the bed
headboard
and i turned on the light
big mistake
when i turned that light on there was a
head
without a body
floating like a balloon and it had long
skin hanging down
and all this matted hair
and i was watching him go like this in
front of me and i thought anything any
second he's going to go whoosh right
into my face
but i just did not i didn't even blink i
was just watching him and he went into
the closet hmm and i thought well man i
can't go to sleep with him in there
so i quietly got out of here did you
watch a lot of movies as a kid
yes
but ours were sweet guys like the
werewolf
they weren't demons
i could handle those i knew what to do
with those guys so i now have a mistake
so i tiptoed out of bed and i grabbed my
bible
as soon as i had that in my hand oh good
good so i said now you dude
so i opened the closet door wider oh
you're brave i put the bible in front of
me you know and i said i know you're in
here but there's between me and you it's
called god's shield amen so i started
pulling the
hangers back
and
any second i thought that face is going
to pop out and go
right into my face you know
but i just kept pulling the hangers back
pulling the hangers back nothing
thank you jesus and for the next year or
two i would not go to sleep without a
bible within arm's reach of my hand
because whenever it happened again i
would simply open the bible i wasn't
going to
deal with him i wasn't going to i just
started reading scripture
even when i went camping pocket into
sleeping bag pocket bible and if
anything funny happened that thing came
right out and i just started reading i
didn't want to look i didn't want to
feel nothing i'm just reading scripture
we're done that's the proper response i
don't believe that you should engage
with them communicate with him i think
there's power in jesus's name i mean
that we we showed on that alien
documentary that we made you know it's
like out of all these deceptions
hundreds of accounts where people had
been taken up into a spaceship and
brought out of that simply by the name
by using the name of jesus and so you
know having the word of god in your
hands or knowing it or reading it and
then you know calling upon jesus name
i've heard this story over and over and
over again those demons will flee at the
name of jesus a friend of mine went and
saw the exorcist
and i was a brand new christian that was
early 1970s 74 74.
and uh she called me up and i was a
brand new adventist and she called me up
she says i'm gonna go see the actress i
said are you crazy girl i said you don't
go see the outskirts demons can follow
you home you've given them permission
number one just more
uh you know powerful than the other one
they said the
exorcist one is the worst didn't people
like faint and there was like always
like these like you know people having
to get have medical help from watching
the movie yeah yeah yeah my dad used to
have the book in the house
yeah
so she she's i'm going anyway she says i
read the book i know what to expect i
said i'm telling you i said don't come
crying to me if something happens
because i'm a new christian i don't i
don't fool around so she went to the
exorcist
about two o'clock in the morning phone
rings
she i said hello she goes can i get over
here i said would you do she says i told
you i went to the exorcist she says you
got to come over here i said i ain't
coming over there
you're a christian you got to help me
and i said i'm a baby christian and i'm
not going into battle
she's come on you got to help me jesus
there's something outside my window i
said i don't doubt it it's a demon
because that's not funny and i said i
know it's not funny i said i don't got a
demon they followed you home she goes oh
what am i gonna do you know i said but
don't be saying no prayers to mary cause
i ain't gonna help you
she was a catholic so she says
tell me anything
i tell what we'll do she goes what i
said i'll get into bed and i'll start
reading the bible out loud you jump in
the bed you read the bible out loud and
you just keep reading out loud until you
go to sleep she said you promised me
you're gonna do that i said i promise to
god i will do that she was all right all
right you promised i said i will
so we hang up the phone i jump in the
bed read three verses close the ball
i didn't say i love you i was going to
read it
did it go away yep wow yeah she called
me the next morning and she says i'm not
doing any of that stuff anymore i said
listen you don't go near that stuff wow
you don't go listen to any music you
don't go nothing like that if you don't
think it's coming from god it's the
other guy yeah and if it's not clear
it's from god then when in doubt leave
it out no yeah i don't care if it's food
music
i mean what do you think they call it
devil's food cake
i was seven years old
and i was sleeping
and
that was big room
three beds my brothers and the door was
open to go to the living room
and i was awake
i was it was very cold and i was
sweating cold
and i was like what's going on i was
like seven eight years old and this
voice coming from
that door
tell me
can i come in
and i seriously like it was the voice it
was
a
girl
i mean not older woman or something like
that it was you know
nice and sweet
if you want to put it away
but they said my name my first name is
israel
so it's israel can i come in
and they asked me three times
and i was so sweating cold i don't know
if you have that feeling sweating cold
that is terrible and you know of course
you know i was literally whatever and i
you know
covered myself but i remember i used to
just kind of like look it outside right
but i never uh i said yes or no or
everything but i had i mean it was not a
dream nothing i mean i
remember i mean i you know
and i asked my parents like hey you hear
these boys sometimes no we're here
but uh since
uh
i mean we see in the bible you know uh
things about demon possessing everything
for children
and you know the then the enemy wants to
deceive us you know wants to i don't
know because you're not well trained yet
yeah you haven't had all these years
just full of years of study or something
like that that's a seed planted like no
you know
that little girl wanted to play with me
or whatever
to you that could be a reality i know
yeah i think devil's pulling out all the
stops now because i think we're on the
last lap yes you know like doug batcher
said gentlemen i think we have entered
the early time of trouble
and i i watched uh my day star satellite
and my attorney broadcasting also and i
mean all of my sunday brothers and
sisters are saying people it's over it's
over get ready get ready get ready
yeah but i want to end with an angel
story if we're uh yes yes please sir i
don't want them getting all the glory i
have a couple of angel stories but one
that was really amazing to me um i was
uh up at doug cooper's house for a
christmas party he wrote the book
leaving god's love
and at the end of the party i was coming
down the hill the mountainside
and
i saw the road i was supposed to turn
off i was getting missing so i i didn't
know now what you do in snow is i whip
the wheel over so i wouldn't pass the
road and the car went right into the
ditch uh deep dish i mean that the
wheels were buried the whole front of
the car and then i got to run back and
get a tow truck
and uh as i closed the car door this guy
ran up behind me in a t-shirt
and he said get in the car
i'll push you out that's not that car's
not coming out it's packed in when you
pack in snow it's like cement it's not
moving i said i'm gonna have to get a
tro truck he said just get in the car
so he digs his weight to get around the
front of the car so i thought okay i'll
humor him so i get in the car start it
up put it in reverse before i step on
the gas pedal the car flew out of the
ditch i had to slam on the brake not to
go to the other ditch oh wow as soon as
i slammed on the brake threw it in park
i got out and nobody was there oh wow
here i was in the middle of the
mountainside with deep snow
and i wanted to thank him and i looked
up and i said thanks yeah wait so
it was did he have a car or two or he
just showed up at a he just showed up
out of nowhere t-shirt not dressed for
the snow yeah he came running up behind
me and he said get in the car i'll push
you out oh wow and i thought
this car's not going out
and everybody always asks what does he
look like and i don't know what happens
if the lord erases it from our memory or
just has a vague but i i can't tell you
what his face looked like white t-shirt
that's all i remember wow white t-shirt
and uh he got and he i mean that car was
like it was airlifted you know and i
just slammed on the brakes
all that didn't take 10 seconds
and when i got out there was nobody wow
no nobody running down the street nobody
yeah so i just looked up and i said
thank you amen
so i have a question for you uh you know
you mentioned you know you sweet
girl you know passed away you know stuff
like that
do you remarry uh
what happened you love for her you now
that you believe that she's gonna be you
know
the lord is gonna resurrect her you know
i mean what is the plan so what happened
you know
throughout college i dated a couple
girls i got proposed to a couple of
times you got proposed to i did yeah
well you know what i have prayer warrior
friends and whenever something big is
supposed to come up you know the first
biggest decision of your life is
jesus christ your second business
decision is your life calling the third
one is who or if you should marry
and i always try to explain that when i
go to the academies and stuff like that
you got three decisions in your life
jesus your calling and if or who you
should marry because the if you should
marry it's supposed to be the help mate
to carry out your mission
it's not because she's a good cook or
because she's prettier she can sing oh
it's because she's a help mate to your
ministry whatever you're called to do
so
anyway
it was interesting when i was in france
telling this story i was in the largest
adventist church in all of france new
year in paris
and my translator was so emotionally
caught up in this story that he signaled
another translator he was crying and he
left the pulpit and so another man come
up and he finished the translation and
when i got down the parisians just
they said you know paul you're a
frenchman in heart you know he said you
gave your little heart at 17 years old
to this beautiful girl
and uh you will never give it to another
and they said we we believe god is
saving you for her
and i said but there's no marriage or
given in marriage in heaven they said
boy we're only in heaven for the
millennium
that is a whole other topic
we did talk a little bit about that too
and in the bible it does talk in isaiah
it talks about the
little kids will play with the cobra and
the snakehole and stuff so there's going
to be kids in eternity somehow i don't
know i don't know how that all works out
yeah i i believe that
when you you get resurrected you don't
come up as an adult you know and there's
been lots of children who have died but
the children will
age and there wouldn't be any children
anymore at some point in time unless
we're populating again once we have
immortality we have no need to propagate
that's why the angels don't have to
propagate because the angels are not
going to die off
and so when we have immortality the need
for propagating and my understanding is
that
we're actually the group that replaced
the fallen angels who left
that's my understanding and so
at any rate uh
yeah
i i've asked the lord i said do you have
a help mate for me
i even went on these
dating sites and i've been to singles
retreats i've spoken at singles retreats
and i said lord if you've got some bells
and whistles i said i know what they
sound like because when i saw chris boy
it was bells and whistles i knew
immediately this was the girl so i said
if you if you have a helmet for me
but maybe i'm just not fit to be married
whatever the case lord
you can do that and and i i pray when i
go to places you know overseas or
whatever even coming down here to
tennessee i said lord you have a help
made for me you turn on the bells and
whistles and i'll i'll respond
but
no bells no whistles i believe that's
how we are supposed to actually treat
anything in life whether your job
whether lord what do you want me to do
yeah what do you where do you want me to
go to the right of the left let him
direct your paths and you will not be
sorry for that it won't be a mistake so
so paul thank you so much for sharing
tell our audience if somebody out there
has interacted with some supernatural
event
what should they do
you know sometimes we make mistakes by
ignorance
sometimes we make it by rebellion
but once you have been shown the light
and we have materials here that we can
get to you to
clarify this even more from scripture
that you have no question in your mind
whenever you have an encounter that's a
supernatural encounter you need to be
certain if it is uh an angelic visit or
if it's from the other world and when
you start talking about jesus if it's an
angelic visit they're going to be with
you and happy but if it's from the other
place they start getting really upset
and then that's when you need to clearly
do what i did and that says in the name
of the lord jesus christ i rebuke you
amen they have to go amen that's right
test the spirits that's what the bible
tells us to do
well thank you guys for for checking out
today's show thank you paul for coming
by if you guys want to see
more uh content from paul where where do
where can people get a hold of you or
how can they get to you know i'm all
over youtube i'm told i have like 50
presentations i've never watched any of
them nice but from all over the world
you can brush up on your german your
serbian your spanish but uh i uh i'm on
youtube and i have a website
nustartplus.org
and i don't know if you want me to give
them the phone number or uh we'll leave
it in the description below as long as
you're not a realtor i'm i don't have
realtor phone calls or if you're running
for office so don't
yeah well thank you paul and we hope
that you guys were blessed um it is
a crazy world out there and as we are
nearing getting nearer and nearer to
when we see jesus coming in the clouds
we don't want to be deceived and we
don't want anyone to take us off of our
path and that is to
literally get to the place where we can
see jesus coming in the clouds and live
with him forever so um check this out if
if you have any questions comments we
welcome you guys to leave it below we do
take every question and comment
seriously we will respond to them um and
so if you have any questions about this
uh we'll put some bible verses in the
links and descriptions to check out but
we've got a lot of other pieces of
information on this exact topic as well
so thumb through some of our videos if
you're new here we're thanking you for
stopping by today don't forget to like
and subscribe to our channel and we hope
to see you next friday
[Music]
you